hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to shadows 2 now I hope
to finish the game and I'm hoping that
this works everybody cross your fingers
I think we're there I think is where we
left off right floor 6 ok so I'm gonna
try to get through all the floors right
now immediately and hopefully I can get
to the bottom of the mystery of this
whole office and why we're here of which
I do not know hello anybody in the
bathroom Olo well that's a new
decoration on my bed why did I take that
why did I need a skull why do I bring
skull did I put it in my pants
do I have skull pants hello
no mannequins in here no my reflection
in here who hey you're new you weren't
there before I would have remembered to
put toothpaste not a key alright so
you're just following me around wherever
I go hi exactly what I would say oh I
can't move
oh there we go hi alrighty then
everything seems fine goodbye have
lovely day
hello a key to success is head oh I get
it I get it
oh why what okay you know what I'm not
gonna question it I'm gonna accept
everything that I see in this game is a
the utmost sure thing of reality and
everything hey hey you got a note you
took it away from me again another
goddamn note went missing hey I'm not
gonna follow you I'm gonna go the
counter away never mind there's nothing
over here I'm coming for you I'm gonna
strangle you even though you don't have
a head I'm already here
oh hi uh cool ha dude
do you hear that no okay [ __ ] off I
should hide somewhere before noise door
closes closet closet bathroom
I'm the bathroom oh I'm a dime on a dime
oh I can't find anywhere to hide I'm in
needed I'm a [ __ ] idiot
Oh God what huh I didn't do nothing
I may have taken a skull and put into my
pants and disrespected the Dead and I
may have flirted with a few too many
mannequins in my life but that doesn't
mean that I deserve this whatever's
happening whatever it may be whatever
you may be looking at okay alrighty hey
secret cool got a secret that's always
good glad I got that what was that a
couch did a couch just dive as quickly
as it could
huh ready then Oh
okay call my breath they're pretty good
that's okay I think it's gone by now
what you think what's gone by now I
don't know why you're talking again I'm
away
yeah you better back off right so what
was that all about huh huh no I barely
survived this time that thing was so
close to me one move and I could be dead
let's keep moving okay one move and I
could be dead better keep moving then
huh there's no way to go but forward
this guy's brew it alrighty then they
need to chill with the goddamn
mannequins because I'm not having noon
it is hello come out come out where you
are
Oh No in the toilet that's is a common
behavior you can't escape from it it's
already here there there it's there
already face it you can try to avoid it
but you'll fail soon enough hi should I
stick that skull in my pants oh is this
what this metaphor was alluding to all
along whoa
well dive right in okay thank you it was
good I enjoyed it thank you have lovely
day oh oh good uh-huh what is happening
Oh God oh well my vision went perturbed
my FAC and brain something interrupts it
badly I need to find some meds somewhere
yeah probably good idea you know the
meds storage in your local office that
you what a [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are you
who da [ __ ] whoa what's with your head
Oh what's with your head hi
this isn't real how do you know you
don't know that isn't real I mean my god
you won't look at me actually don't look
at me never mind don't do that I'm gonna
just go I'm gonna go now I'm gonna go
now doesn't work that's great at the
comforting so I need to find oh that's
right there was a medicine cabinet over
here for some frickin reason Mads did I
get some
good everything's better now
everything's hunky-dory oh and good this
is working now
good great hi down we go
I suppose I bet I miss some secrets here
and there man we got a lot of floors
left to go but I'm hoping to conquer
them all 50 booth pip who's right every
step I'm closer to the exit I'm half the
way now so wonder if anyone's alive left
besides me nah no one in the whole wide
world no one at all all right who else
is here
whoa what the hell who rearranged my
furniture everybody in the bathroom come
out come out bathroom office room what
bathroom office room I think you're
confused I'm pretty sure you don't know
what you're talking about
pretty sure bathroom officer does that
mean bathroom to the office room am I
supposed to go from one to the other
what I had a phone like this five
minutes ago what is it doing here well I
know
hello fifteen bathroom office room 15
this makes sense question mark are you
guys able to make any sense out of this
oh hi what's going alright I don't even
bother to say hi to those I love your
butt whoa no you do not
well the Krays must ever huh oh why do
you love my butt what why do you why why
do you love who I love your butt tonight
if I supposed to look deep into this
butt crack huh
all right fine then okay you love my
butt produce you're planning people do
32 15 32 is that it yeah super secret
code that I need bathroom office room 15
32 I don't know that okay 15:32
wink wrong code wrong code eat a child
wrong code come on
oh here we go 26 I didn't see this
before okay so 26 26 1532
would that be the one I guess the order
would be 26 1532 that would be it right
26:15 32 - bingo
got it okay got it I'm a genius I'm a
Jew
oh sure
something something was over here for a
bug are you all right bye
okay goodbye okay halfway done
whoa know what no how about your digging
with me now oh it seems like something
open the elevator and it doesn't let me
use it
hmm okay oh hey
what whoa that uh you're oh you're
[ __ ] dead no I'm not I'm alive I'm
alive man what do you do why what the
[ __ ]
okay okay okay all right we're fine hmm
hmm oh good come on Oh mark he doesn't
want to find you I should do that huh hi
no one's home don't listen to my
screaming voice maybe I should answer
the door oh hi what oh hello oh it was
an illusion
what so I'm not alone here at least it
seems so that was a person I'm sure too
bad he's gone now I should go look for
him yeah baby not considering all the
dead bodies row all the dead bodies
think of the bodies
oh hey secret was it going uh come out
come back wherever you are I don't want
to find you I'm gonna find you in pieces
and bits all over the place oh I was too
late alone again yeah I was just too
late
I can't hear and talk after what it done
to me I brought you my note and hope you
can help me I'm trapped in the building
and I can't explain
unexplained happenings occurred I can
see weird black shapes I feel very
unpleasant energy going through my body
I need some water please if you can take
me out of here I'll follow you just give
me a sign well I think that was the
sound of the elevator probably working
too bad for that guy so sad
oh well he was just a lad let's get out
of here
okay ah that's a dick dick dick a tree
dick the goddamn Dickie dick oh [ __ ] me
what now what now
got my intense brightness on got my
hater blockers come out come out
wherever yeah what he just bad back
flipped into a black hole
oh god [ __ ] okay who's well you Bob done
in there boy you really you really had
to go MIT may I come in uh all right
yeah yeah y'all go on I guess okay
goodbye ha [ __ ] off
alright it's getting me with the cheap
ones now it's skidding sheep follow me
oh is this a sign follow me come on
follow me
I'm coming oh oh oh what that oh hello
hi
was ice book touch me oh I don't know if
I wanna Wow
oh if you insist wink okay
did I put you in my pants hi boink oh I
can't touch you again okay that was a
fun game glad we did the [ __ ] off with
you you can't hurt me yes they want to
kill you every time you see one run away
don't look at them all they want us to
kill you that's what keeps them alive
that's what keeps them alive total
destruction killing innocent people I
looked over to the side because I had a
shirt on my chair over there never mind
this is theory saying that shadows are
the dead people doing things they did in
their lifetime if you get trapped in the
building know to be haunted by them I
have very bad news for you you probably
won't survive the best thing to do is
just stay away from these places oh yeah
I think it's a little too late for that
besides why was this why was this place
haunted
unless there's gonna be probably some
twist ending where I'm the shadow person
and these shadows are actually real
people a number stop it stop what are
you doing hey what what what what the
hey what are you doing hey what are you
doing Oh hard you gerbil Oh Oh No he's a
little guy always trashcan Steve okay
I'm not bad please help me can you see
what they did to me take me out of here
I don't want to be alone I remember
leaving my bag in the toilet there was
something what you need right now please
go there you're very lucky for surviving
that long they didn't even look at me
and now I am a trash can my god don't
worry I'll help you trashcan Steve trash
can I wouldn't I would call you trash
can Tim but Tim's already been named
someone and you got to be something that
kind of reminds me of trash can so
Steve's about the best that I can do
come along Steve go on little buddy
oh you're so cute maybe trash can Tyler
I don't know dad done flow oh well did
you did you do this okay
princess sees what you do what did you
try again Steve oh I don't know object
the truck dude alright thanks Steve
would you have a go on okay you're gonna
just keep following me around like that
you're freaking weirdo oh sure I don't
know man
I got another nose at you I've gotta be
living life being a trash can it's not
very interesting at all but whatever
pretty cool I guess okay all right Steve
you have a great one you have a good day
a good day now you trashcan Steve Steve
oh you're still there
thank goodness I was almost worried
right so what did I get in the bag
backpack only some water drink it oh
okay look look hmm oh [ __ ] that was some
hard water Steve what have you done to
me put only my master plan you've all
right into my trap
you activated my trap card trash can
she's gonna steal your body you're gonna
be dressed you in hell okay Steve you
know what
Fairplay can't really argue with that
logic thanks man
you're the only one that actually
understands me all right I'm gonna
Google [ __ ] off then does he gone
it's trashcan Steve gone for three well
[ __ ] I made it somehow nah crap my
flashlight doesn't work how about this
no energy left all right
okay I got a glow stick it's not much
but I got it I think Steve must have
taken my [ __ ] what a douche that Steve
guy locked from behind is Steve in there
with my body probably Oh what the [ __ ]
was that okay
you gonna do it again that's what I
thought but back off oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy can't see anything
oh boy oh boy whoa whoa can't see
anything
whoa I can't see anything I couldn't
have run out of batteries already got a
key damn it
I'm my cell ran out of batteries when I
had it on higher energy mode or else
this was planned not Harvison sure okay
okay there we go I need to hide
huh I don't know how he missed me oh man
that was legitimately terrifying like
legitimately terrifying thanks for the
head up heads up voice in my head
god I wish I had some batteries I
couldn't have wasted them all I probably
should have I probably did damnit can't
see a goddamn thing unless is this is
probably intentional mana bouncing back
and forth whether it's intentional or
not just better
hi are you welcoming into your warm
loving embrace down here probably come
out come out wherever you are
mark is gonna find you come out come out
ow my back and neck ow that's all I can
say I tensed everything up ow ow hey
[ __ ] off jeez get up get out of the way
hi are you guarding that can I get
through please
unmovable hopefully I can break them
with something heavy well if they're
unmovable than that be doubtful but I
got a key which I can only assume it's
gonna go back to the original room what
the hell happened to my mic my mic got
all tossed uh jeez that last one got me
good
I got me real good all right but
hopefully there's a door here damn it
god damn it where can I go ah
sassafras has got to be a way it could
be a route well I can't go there so it
must have been one of the doors to the
left here down one of these corridors ah
so blind gate whoops
should have been this one okay say
you're Steve see if you better not
follow me I'm pissed at you
what happen your voice Steve uh maybe
your do you Lewis okay Steve whatever
you doing you gotta do okay all right
bye Steve haha
alright that was I'm weary of you weary
we're almost there I think just two more
floors and we should be good ah yep two
more floors okay
oh do I my flashlight back now does it
actually know it still doesn't have
juice okay fine glow stick it is unless
I don't even have the glow stick not
working anymore well [ __ ] you man okay
good we got flashlight batteries
all right everyone reading this please
run to the elevator something unarmed
just roaming through the office and even
if it has no weapons it's dangerous
enough to cause bad damage to you please
do not ignore this message get to the
exit quickly and run to the air safe
building how do you know what building
is safe why not run madly in the street
screaming your head off that's the way
that I'd approach all my problems Oh
Billy err joy hello hi I'll be with you
in a second I want to play whoa hi Wow
okay I was just gonna look at the pool
table for a hot second all right I'm a
common baby what [ __ ] was that what
happened we you didn't move but all them
moves
why what happened I want to get in there
let me through
move your boobs all right fine be that
way
be that way anything over here oh that's
a silhouette of a man hey the door is
locked for safety reasons please use the
following code 25 times three plus five
remember to head directly to the
elevator and then the exit door be
careful so eighty is that the code or is
it actually 280 oh okay
okay uh fi that's fine that's fine
that's fine I just want to make sure
that I got everything before I bolt on
out of here bye Steve bye I don't
remember what I did the [ __ ] was that
was that in the gamer in my house oh my
god
it was his chica scratching at her bed I
was like what the hell that naughties oh
man cuz it sounded so realistically in
Maya oh hi hello kind of party is it
over what is this whoa what the hell
what the hell is this
I can cause use this drone to find med
something because something is messing
with my brain again what why wouldn't
you just go I guess to get through here
maybe alright bye ladies can I get
through here
there are some meds in here pretty
please oh okay I see what you're doing I
don't know why you needed this excuse
are those eye drops
okay what Avenue what happening okay bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye ah [ __ ]
off with you okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay I thought when I came back I
would see something standing behind me
or something but I got some meds I don't
know it doesn't seem to be there anymore
but I got him
mmm-hmm okay good I didn't want to play
one last game I come out come out
wherever you are
but at least I got my oh there's no
elevator mmm that's peculiar
hmm so what do I do
oh wait there okay I got it thank you
now I can know oh now I'm just high on
drugs
oh it's behind me isn't it hi Hey nice
ass I like your butt what was that well
that whoa hi how are you doing hello
friend
what uh oh okay should i I shoot what
high off with you oh oh what oh oh I
guess I will sense says I probably
shouldn't have ran towards the obvious
bad guy but come on curiosity got the
best to me all right I'll be right back
okay so now then I'm back I'm not gonna
walk towards the dudes and I'm just
gonna run out of here
I Baba okay down to floor 1 which means
lat floor which probably means that I'm
going to get purged out here probably
not knowing how these horror games go
definitely know how these horror games
go I'm almost done
good what could go wrong I'm two days
from retirement all right let's do this
even though it's exactly the same layout
we won't let you go try and stop me what
with your murder hands I don't think you
can you're mine oh so you're just one
person now you'll die in an agonizing
pain in just one agonizing pain come on
now I can take at least seven agonizing
pains no okay
that door doesn't work and there's
something thumping on the run did you
not tell me twice
okay wait a minute
jussie Exeter is there something else oh
geez move the chair alrighty then thank
you for sticking to our advices please
leave the building and head to the
nearest safe place gas station etc make
sure to call this number next eat next
okay six six zero two ninety five oh
[ __ ] come on
okay got it alright boink no I got a
number gonna call it iose kappa'd I was
one of the luckiest people this day not
many made it to the exit alive therefore
I will never forget what horror I went
through Oh only because of that no one
will ever know what really happened
there uh-huh
hey that's en ok so that was really good
I like that I like that a lot it scared
me a whole bunch it had moments where it
broke the atmosphere and it didn't seem
all that scary and admittedly it was a
little repetitive because the layout was
exactly the same but it did a lot it did
a lot with very little and I liked it
anyway he only started in May of this
year so you know not not that long
making it but still it was pretty damn
good for being something that was
legitimately scary and rough around the
edges but it's totally fine for a free
game not that better was it free I can't
remember I think it was free but either
way thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you developer for making
this game I'm gonna check on the main
menu because I believe there was
something that said secrets but I don't
know if I found all the secrets so I
don't know if that's going to help any
secrets collect all secret still
unlocked interesting facts and
supervision good game ok so I don't have
that yeah I don't have it I didn't get
all of them I missed a few so sorry
about that but maybe if you play the
game you can unlock the secrets for
yourself I'll bowling in the description
thank you everybody so much for watching
be sure to check out all the other scare
games that I played there's a huge
playlist upload link in the description
over 200 videos of cheery games and
stuff like that so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video